we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
good question when has a politician
evolved when as a politician merely
flip-flopped hi David Tom I'm from
Phoenix Arizona although originally from
California and I was wondering your
position on whether someone is quote
unquote evolving on issue or whether
they have clip-clop and how whether in
which case would you use one term versus
another because it seems to me that you
could use depending on how you feel but
it can't on you know an individual both
labels could apply and I'm wondering
where you draw the line between those
thanks a lot right yeah listen you never
you can't say with certitude in every
single case when someone is
flip-flopping for political gain or
whether someone's position has actually
changed but there's sort of two things I
look at number one when they explain
their transition are they using language
that explains why they are why they said
the wrong thing or are they actually
explaining to you why their view has
changed because you will sometimes hear
someone change their position on
something like LGBT rights says as one
example and they won't actually explain
why their position was wrong they will
apologize for the things that they said
and say that they don't stand by those
things anymore in other words the things
insulting to LGBT people that's very
different than saying oh my position was
just misinformed and now I understand
why the rights rather than the slurs are
what I need to change my mind about
saying I was wrong to use the f-word
about gay people is very different than
saying I didn't used to see gay marriage
as equivalent to straight marriage under
the law and now I do and here's why my
position change so you've got to be able
to explain why that happened and it has
to be credible so it's a case-by-case
basis
plenty more today on the bonus show I'm
out of time but make sure you're a
member or a patron so that you get the
bonus show we will have much much more
about all of what happened today with
Michael Cohen on tomorrow's program